hola soy eric lacroix y trabajo en
efectos especiales en pixar
yo soy sarah bet eisinger otra artista
de efectos especiales con efectos nos
referimos a la creación de animación
para cualquier cosa que se mueva pero no
es un personaje los equipos de efectos
especiales creen casi todos los
fenómenos naturales cosas como el polvo
así
fuego
de explosiones
no
um
y los efectos crean agua en todas sus
formas crear agua verosímil en la
computadora es realmente apasionante y
desafiante se debe en parte a que el
agua adopta muchas formas el lago
plácido donde puedes nadar o el río
enfurecido en el que no te gustaría
quedar atrapado el tipo de agua que
creamos depende de la historia que
tratamos de contar y la forma en que la
tratamos es distinta dependiendo de cómo
interactúa con los personajes y qué tan
cerca estamos de ella una de las
herramientas que usamos para crear agua
verosímil en la computadora son las
partículas comencemos con una sola
partícula podemos aplicarle fuerzas como
el viento la gravedad o más partículas
que se empujan y se atraen entre sí al
agregar muchísimas más partículas y
aplicarles esas mismas fuerzas empezamos
a crear agua en la computadora
en el mundo real el agua también está
compuesta de partículas ya que las
moléculas realmente son solo partículas
muy pequeñas y aunque nuestras
partículas son mucho más grandes que las
moléculas sus leyes físicas son
similares así que simulamos las fuerzas
del mundo real mediante el uso de
matemáticas y programación tomaría
muchos años animar individualmente los
millones de partículas que constituyen
el agua de las escenas
ayuda mucho que podamos usar un conjunto
existente de reglas que las partículas
de la computadora puedan seguir
probablemente te estés preguntando cómo
puedo crear agua para las animaciones
excelente pregunta sarah en la siguiente
lección aprenderás acerca de la creación
de agua mediante el uso de partículas y
simulación diviértete y mantente seco